it's a wednesday edition of p-f-t-o-t
that's when we take some extra time to
either talk about things we didn't get
to during the show or a topic or two we
may want to talk about a little bit more
and chris i'm going to start with one
that that popped up while we were on the
air
there were quotes recently from colts
coach frank reich regarding not starting
quarterback andrew luck but back up
jacob percet who's entering the final
year of his contract
said reich on 1070 the fan in
indianapolis it's impossible for me to
have a higher opinion of jacoby than i
do i said it last year i think he's a
top 20 quarterback i still say that
after watching him for a year this guy's
really good i tell chris ballard all the
time please don't let him go i don't
care what anybody offers don't let him
go i love jacoby the problem is now i've
gotten to know jacoby and at some point
i hope that it works out for jacoby but
not
now right at least not this year the and
also they don't want jacoby bracel on
the field this year because that means
andrew luck won't be on the field but
this is a high praise from a coach of a
guy who's going to jump into the free
agent market in what eight or nine
months yeah i mean because you know
there's so many things to talk about you
know this is jacoby presents the
starting quarterback and you know you
know again in my rankings you know i had
him in the top 32. he is i mean he's got
size he's athletic and he's got an
awesome arm and i think what frank
wright has probably realized especially
this time of the year andrew luck didn't
practice a lot in otas and couldn't do
mini camp because of the calf strain and
i'm sure with jacoby brissette getting
the extra work and getting another gear
in this system he probably opened eyes
to where they went wow i mean this guy
is he's legit he's big time and i you
know new england i think saw some of
those traits in him and yeah you know
you don't trade a guy like this away
right now not on this team you know this
is a team that i think it can be in that
super bowl conversation you know if
things fall the right way and you don't
trade a good backup quarterback on a
team where you feel like you're a super
bowl caliber team why because gosh if
your starting quarterback goes down and
you don't have a good backup quarterback
you screw the other 52 guys on the team
that go man our team was a super bowl
team and we just didn't have a fail-safe
plan for the most important position on
the team and chris ballot and frank
reich aren't going to let that happen
and you know good for jacoby you're set
really cool by frank reich to say those
things about a guy who's going to be a
free agent a year from now
unless he's just trying to build a trade
market for jacoby versus maybe move him
at some point
but here's the here's the other side of
this chris yeah contract expires
do they apply the franchise tag to
jacoby brissette they've got all that
cap space they got enough cash for jim
irsay to buy various vintage instruments
that are seven figures in price do you
tag and then try to trade brissette the
way that the patriots did with matt
castle a decade ago and the way the
eagles considered doing it with nick
foles until they realized there wasn't
going to be anybody out there to trade
for him and they were potentially going
to be stuck with falls at 25 million
dollars i mean percent at 25 26 million
would be making more than andrew luck as
the backup quarterback but they've got
the cap space to do it if they want to
they do they got the cap space i think
it's unlikely that they'll want to do
that i mean i do but what about to trade
him yeah i could do it to trade right if
they felt like yeah they got that okay
there's that's more of a realistic
possibility i do think that that's a
possibility now will teams really want
to trade if that's the case and they
can't kind of negotiate or they can
negotiate after the fact you're right
right so i forgot about that too so yeah
i think that's a real possibility but uh
i certainly don't think it'll be a
franchise and and try to keep them there
but you know the other thing mike i just
want to hit on there you know it it is
not a good look and not cool we didn't
get a chance to talk about this week
that you know the colts are a team with
all this cap space and their owner is
out there buying toys for himself for a
million dollars a pop all the time it's
just not cool i mean you know to me as a
guy that's a fan of the game and wants
wealth spread to the players uh i i
don't really love that part of it well
you know what colts fans got upset that
we made that point recently when it was
five million dollars that was spent by
jim irsay to buy a couple of guitars and
get a car case they've got 55 million in
cap space yeah and the point and look
one of the things that needs to happen
in the next cba
that minimum spending requirement needs
to go up right now it's 89 percent on a
four-year average it needs to be up in
the mid-90s these teams need to be
forced to spend that money because that
is money that you just suck right off
the top it's 11 cents on the dollar
right that you can retain the whole idea
is supposed to be we have a salary cap
to limit the
propensity of teams to spend more if
they could well if you if you have teams
that aren't even spending 90 percent and
they're carrying so much cap space and
the owner is buying all these expensive
toys instead yeah i think it's a fair
concern so i'm glad you raised it
anybody who has a problem with it uh
directed to csimsqb on twitter not to
pro football talk although we we tend to
agree on that point yeah all right let's
move on to the next subject and this is
von miller the super bowl 50 mvp raving
about a new teammate a guy who ended up
not sticking around in miami a first
round pick that they decided not to
resign jajuan james playing right tackle
four-year 51 million contract in denver
and miller says he's the best right
tackle i've had to go against in
practice throughout my entire career
uh james and i get to spar
get better sharpen the sword every day
with him and left tackle garrett bowles
it's gonna be a great year for the
offense and the defense and you know we
shouldn't or we should focus on this
more than we do the quality of the
competition on your practice field makes
you better right it makes you better and
going against von miller is going to
make juwan james better and if james is
better than what miller's gone against
in the past and practice is going to
make him better is too right that that's
why the seahawks have been as good as
they've been they embrace that level of
competition sure on the practice field
competition wednesdays go out there and
work hard against each other get better
against each other then it's easier when
you gotta face an opponent no doubt you
know you play another team and you go oh
gosh i mean this guy they got starting
here isn't as good as the guy i've been
going against all in training camp every
day so yeah it gives you that
self-confidence to go out there and and
be the player you want to be juwan james
there's a reason he was picked in the
first round i mean he has all the tools
to be you know that franchise right
tackle type of specimen i mean he's long
long arms really good feet you know
pretty good in the run game doing all
that but the other thing that jumps out
to me and yeah did he underwhelm a
little bit in miami and like live up to
the draft expectations no not exactly
but i think this is another example mike
to me at least the first thing i thought
of here was okay juwan james talented
guy goes to the broncos and what's
really changed um it's the
dante scarnecki effect it's the mike
munchek effect that's what says changes
when i think about things like this i go
damn yeah here's a talented guy who now
goes to a team who's got a really good
coach at his position
and we go whoa a lot trent brown from
the 49ers to the new england patriots
and so on where you go whoa this guy is
pretty damn good you know what's been
going on oh what's been going on is he
got another coach to teach him a few new
tricks or a few new different aspects of
technique and now his game has gone to
another level and and i would envision
that's what a lot has happened in denver
with juwan james story line number 29 of
the 30 that we're following at pft in
advance of the start of the 2019 season
when will dwayne haskins start in
washington doug williams the senior vp
of player personnel in washington has
raved about haskins and here's the quote
that he gave to steve weiss of nfl
network dwayne might end up starting
that could happen i don't want to say
he's going to start game one today
but it's been enjoyable to see what
dwayne haskins has done so that door is
open yeah for haskins to be the week one
starter and chris you made this point
yesterday not an easy array of opponents
right out of the gates it could be
baptism by
by fire for dwayne haskins if he ends up
starting week one but maybe that's what
they decide to do it's worked with other
quarterbacks where it accelerates that
learning curve and if they're ever going
to be great quarterbacks they're going
to survive that yeah they're going to be
better right because of it right no
doubt there's nothing in practicing
quarterback in the nfl is very hard to
do it's the hardest position in all
sports to practice you just can't
emulate the real you know the realness
of an nfl football game with the fans
and the intensity and now you're live
and the defensive ends can rip your head
off and all of those things you know so
yeah you're out of your comfort zone
where practice is a lot more comfortable
for the most part but the one thing that
continues to ring true here and you know
i know i said it a few weeks ago when
they started out on otas with dwayne
haskins i mean i heard pretty right away
where it was one of those things where
he jumped out on the practice field and
i think a lot of the coaches and people
in the organization looked at each other
and went whoa
okay this guy's a little more talented
than maybe i gave him credit for and we
kind of continue to hear these kind of
things whether it's jay gruden you know
at the start of otas or ending the mini
camp or now here doug williams once
again nonetheless it sounds like
everything is going in the right
direction for dwayne haskins and that
they're extremely impressed with who he
is and the talent level that he has to
this point but yeah the beginning of the
season
that's that's going to be the big
question is he ready mentally to
orchestrate the offense and handle some
of those defenses early on
and who's making that call is it jay
gruden who possibly needs a playoff
appearance this year to stick around for
2020 or is it somebody hiring the
organization saying sorry jay this is
our quarterback put dwayne haskins on
the field even if it means we go six and
ten even if it means we're looking for a
new coach in 2020 new coach in arizona
this year for the second straight year
and cliff kingsbury wanted kyler murray
to be his quarterback but brett hundley
hasn't gotten the memo that the
competition is over brett hundley he he
says he's competing to be the starting
quarterback in arizona he's willing to
help kyler murray but the former ucla
quarterback says uh hey my goal has
always been to start no matter what
position it's in i don't want to be
second that's my goal to get that
starting job and at the same time it's
competition for a reason there are
different types of backup quarterbacks
some who are competing with the starter
others who are supporting the starter
i mean is this just delusion by brett
hundley or do you think there's a way he
could uh convince cliff kingsbury that
that maybe he's the better option right
out of the gates well you know it's the
right approach by him this is the way he
should be approaching but you stole the
word i was gonna use i mean you're
exactly right i mean this is what makes
athletes really good is they can be
delusional and tell themselves things
that are not true to continue to
motivate them and you know almost make a
false universe into where they think
there's a chance there yeah i mean brett
hundley i love what he's saying i want
him to compete and continue to get
better and act like he's going to be the
starter but
that is their negative ghost rider kyla
murray's the quarterback the pattern is
full okay there is no way anybody else
is starting that quarterback other than
kylo murray i mean he would have to have
an epically
bad preseason i think for that to happen
where he literally throws like
six interceptions in the preseason and
it's the only way i see that happen
other than that kyla murray's the guy
and that's why they picked him number
one
and that's why i think some teams will
install that rookie quarterback at
number three on the depth chart
initially and force him to work his way
up yeah so he develops that confidence
there's a sense he's earned it and and
you have that that uh fallback in the
event that he does stick you don't have
to demote him you just leave him where
he is right right we put him at three we
expect him to be one but if he stinks
then it's easier to keep him there than
move him down so uh look they're all in
with this guy i i'd be shocked if it's
anybody but kyler murray's starting week
one but i like the confidence it's like
amari cooper saying i want 2 000
receiving yards it's unrealistic but if
it motivates you every day to be the
best that you can be and that's the
thing that you do to push your own
buttons then so be it so brett hundley
and i i remember when brett hundley was
at ucla thinking this guy can you know
there's so many guys who come out of
college that we think they could be good
quarterbacks and there still aren't
enough good quarterbacks to go around a
pretty good receiver in new england in
the form of julian edelman he won the
super bowl 53 mvp award we spent a lot
of time talking during the show about
ped use whether or not julian edelman
has ever been truly accountable has he
ever been pressed on what he took why he
took it and did he know he was cheating
that he was taking something at the time
he took it that was a violation of the
ped policy or was it like so many other
guys who say well you know i hey i just
took a supplement that was spiked with
something he's never been pressed to
answer that i think that that his
silence is deafening in that regard and
tells me he did know what he was doing
yeah he did take a ped in order to
accelerate his recovery from that torn
acl he suffered in the 2017 preseason
but chris look
you made a good point maybe the nfl in
the nfl pa should negotiate a small
range of injuries for which certain
types of peds are permissible to allow
that recovery process to happen faster
so the guys can get back on the field
right they take all sorts of other crap
that isn't a ped to get back on the
field prescription painkillers etc
maybe there are some things small
category narrow range of things that god
can take okay fine negotiate that how
about show that you give a crap about
cheating though and at the same time
you're negotiating that let's make the
punishment more stringent for a guy who
does test positive and how about this do
what baseball does you get four games
and you don't get to play in the
playoffs right that's something you've
said several times as it relates to
julian edelman maybe that's what the
punishment should be and without that
kind of a punishment is it a surprise
that people don't care about ped use
more than 50 percent in the poll
question that we posted today don't care
it doesn't seem like the nfl cares it
seems like it's just checking a box it's
not nearly the punishment that it should
be for cheating the game cheating the
sport yeah taking a substance that
artificially makes you bigger faster
stronger than you otherwise would be
yeah right well and then julian edelman
case is certainly not going to scare
anybody away from doing it oh oh i can
take it i lose four games and then be
celebrated after the season oh you what
you a great playoff run you win the
super bowl mvp and just everybody
celebrates them and you know i mean gosh
there was talk there member of the super
bowl week is julian edelman a hall of
famer and i was like my brain was
blowing up i mean whoa and again i don't
know to what extent did he take it to
get healthy was he taking this for
performance levels i don't know all that
i want to think he was taking him to be
healthy but regardless at the end of the
day like you're saying he cheated these
are the rules they are right now and
it's unfair to the other people who did
it the right way to try to heal from
injuries or if he was trying to get
better it's unfair to the you know the
players who are doing it the right way
too and just going out there and
drinking protein shakes and working hard
and doing it that way too to where i go
you're cheating a lot of people uh a lot
as well as that but you know
i am shocked that people don't care as
much as they do uh i know it really
bothers me but to what you said first
too mike um you know i agree i just
think you know hopefully we can find a
way
the the the the suspension of the
playoff thing i think should happen you
got to hit these players harder you
either got to hit them harder with the
playoff suspension or something more
games or you got to make the what you
tested positive for in the pd scale uh
you need to make it public to give
players the fear of embarrassment right
i think that would certainly stop some
players to go oh i can't use the i
accidentally took something from gnc
that i didn't know about yeah sure go
kiss my butt with those excuses i'm so
sick of that crap
but but i do want to find a fine line
rare for torn acl torn achilles torn
patella tendon you know
maybe it's a month after the surgery
you're allowed to take these pd's to
help accelerate the process of rehabbing
and getting people back to their
strength because it is their profession
and uh it is how they're making a living
as well
yeah and look i i i can get behind the
idea of expanding the list or narrowing
the list rather banned substances under
certain circumstances but you know on
that la on on one of the points you made
in that last response the idea that
there is a difference between
recovering from an injury versus just
trying to get better do you believe that
it's different because in my mind it's
the same ped uses ped use there is no
exception currently right for recovering
from injury now maybe there should be
under certain circumstances but you know
over 60
of the people who responded to our other
question today see a difference between
using a ped to recover from an injury
versus you and using a ped just to go
get bigger faster and stronger it's the
same thing folks well it's cheating
regardless as the way it's laid out
right now but i think what players are
saying i mean what the people i would
guess are saying or at least my thought
of this is yeah i do look at it as a
little differently i mean
yeah i do i mean if you're if you're
really banged up and hurt and you you
needed to take a ped to help to
strengthen the ligaments and do all that
yes within the rules of the letter of
the law right now i know it's cheating
but i look at that as less egregious
right than the guy who's totally healthy
and it's you know it's march april may
june and he's just giving himself more
hgh or more whatever it is and he's
getting all of a sudden he went from
four five four to now he's four four
nine and he weighs 15 or 20 pounds more
and he can squat 100 pounds more and he
can bench press another 50 pounds that's
where i go no that's just crazy that's
bs you're cheating you're breaking laws
now you're you're endangering other
people on the football field because
you're excessively bigger and stronger
than you should be and it's not fair to
the guys that are healthy also
endangering themselves i i do think the
reason we see these like non-contact acl
injuries at times is because i go
guys are just they're bigger and
stronger than their body was intended to
be at times and i go that's why your
knee gave out and i think hgh can play a
role into that with
performance-enhancing drugs with guys
being too strong or too big or too
powerful for what their body was really
made to be
here's the bottom line the rule is
currently very clear there is a specific
list of substances that players are
prohibited from taking and it is a
strict liability standard if the
substance is in your body if it is
detected in that urine test you are
tested positive you have violated the
policy and you are suspended four games
and the thing that irritates me more
than anything else is that you know
under the excuses we've heard over the
last 30 years they've never caught an
actual deliberate cheater right every
guy well i didn't realize what i was
taking okay how can it be that every guy
that ever gets caught says that that
means they've never actually caught
someone who actually was consciously
deliberately cheating and it could be
that julian edelman is the closest thing
to that because he's the one guy who
hasn't come out and said he got a bad
supplement somewhere he's just basically
said nothing right which maybe says
everything yeah right i think it does it
says it all he never tried to bs or make
an excuse i mean i could still remember
a thing right before the season where
they was asked about it and he just
looked and said i don't know what you
meant you do know and you knew you were
wrong and you just feel really bad about
it and you don't want to talk about it
and uh you know again i want to root for
julian edelman but this certainly has
made me second guess things for sure
and you know i've already put out poll
question number three now a lot of times
the early results are indicative of what
the ultimate results will be 500 votes
so far just in the last two minutes i
asked this question should players who
violate the ped policy be suspended four
games and banned from postseason play
like baseball already 65 say no wow
people just don't care people chris i
think the the fans it's baked in
the idea that there's no way that
football players are that big that
strong that fast come back from injuries
that quickly unless there's
pharmaceutical enhancement and we're
just okay with it for as as okay as we
aren't with it in baseball we are okay
with it in football yeah i know and
again this is the big you know i know we
talked about this in the show how many
guys do we really feel like are doing in
the nfl and i seem to be a little naive
and low when i talk to people i always
go maybe you know five six seven guys on
a team i know you think it's more i know
there's a lot of ex players that i talk
about that i think are more you know i
think you know to your point where the
general public goes oh man
how could they be this big and strong
you know i don't know maybe i'm
different too but i grew up around it i
played you know football and at the
university of texas you know a lot of
these times these guys that i see are
big and strong you know why they're big
and strong
do you know why they're big and strong
no thank you why are you listening are
you texting i i didn't know you're
waiting for no i didn't know i thought i
thought you you know you know that
that's how normal human conversation
works hey do you know why i did that
i'll tell you why yeah tell me i didn't
know that you were expecting dialogue
there why thank you such good dialogue
right there
because their parents are giant humans
too you know that's the one thing you
know i don't you know think gets glossed
over you've watched the nfl draft before
okay i mean gosh i see moms and dads on
the carpet sometimes and i go whoa you
know mom might be able to play middle
linebacker and dad might be able to play
defensive end and i'm not trying to say
that to be disrespectful but you know
that's why the son is a giant human
being and a physical freak because his
parents are too but i don't know what to
think with this whole thing it's tough i
got i got one last point to make i don't
think you're naive regarding the extent
to which peds were used yeah i think the
locker room generally and i mean this is
a compliment yeah
unless it comes out as an insult but
i'll still say i mean it is a compliment
i think they pegged you as a guy who who
was not going to participate and was not
going to condone and if you saw
something you were going to say
something not that you were going to be
a snitch per se right but i think they
could read that you were a guy that
wasn't going to mess with it and you
weren't going to be happy about it if
anybody was doing it so hey it's we got
we got to keep this away we can't let
chris know we're doing this i think i
think they figured they think they
figured out they were gonna have a real
problem if you knew what was going on i
don't deny that mike i i'd have been the
guy that in the locker room that
probably you know i mean probably i did
i mean
you know uh you know i would speak out
about these type of matters and being
like that's bs if i'm shocked yeah you
know i'm shocked to know that there's a
reason brandon stokely called me the uh
you know s-h-i stirrer he used to call
me that he goes oh gosh here comes the
stir he's coming into the locker room
because he knew i was gonna stir up some
good conversation
well that's why i'm glad you're part of
what we're doing now we got one more day
before our four-week hiatus chris you're
gonna miss me more than you realize now
even if you are running for the eggs
it's one more day for you two more days
for me we'll be back thursday with
another edition of pft live in pftot
great work today chris we'll talk we'll
talk again tomorrow see you man
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports